hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul and
this is mystery languages if you've seen
one of these before then you know how it
goes all play some audio of a language
for you or I'll show you a written
sample of a language and you can guess
what language it is and if you don't
know what language it is maybe you can
guess what language family it belongs to
or what country had spoken in or
anything like that and similar to last
time
today's samples were submitted by Lang
focus viewers on Instagram so let's get
into the first language please listen
aminika semi-firm osa
emma de la cote tober mayo demos varios
animes katrakas hue o una Tartaruga
treadlow so hot oh oh sure dingus - fat
sacado Pushkin's pass on facendo paratha
snow job now let's see that one more
time with writing Amina cosimo Formosa
Emma de la cote Tober mayo demos various
animals katrakas
in Coelho una Tartaruga traklon so hot
oh oh sure dings - fat sacado poses can
space on fazendo who does not shout now
here are a few more written samples que
toma el gouna roba Ella could you live
replaced at of the biblioteca Nogueira's
very Stano t so what language do you
think it might be
[Music]
the language is Galician Galician is a
member of the ribeiro romance branch of
the Romance language family it's spoken
by around 2.4 million people mainly in
Galicia an autonomous community in
northwestern Spain which borders
Portugal to the south
it's a sister language of Portuguese
with the two of them sharing a common
ancestor in the 13th century some
consider Portuguese and Galician to be
two varieties of the same language
because they're closely related and
traditionally formed a dialect continuum
but they do have two separate standard
languages in their respective regions
and many people will insist that they
are indeed independent languages the
sentences we saw have some features
similar to Portuguese for example da a
contraction of de plus aa which would be
de la in Spanish but there are also some
features that are specifically Galician
for example this word fáááád this is a
cognate of the-- nada in Spanish and
Shannara in Italian but in Galician many
nasal sounds have disappeared there were
numerous little phonological
distinctions between Galician and both
Spanish and Portuguese okay on to the
next language please listen
Marisa con Marielena cascada study
intestine Ababa Bolivia Ecuador Peru
volatile and potato soup Takashi Miike
suit this alley Hossam is XML allahu to
sucks
Mauricio tell about Teslas of cogsa
Kunekune last sex his Ponyo hollandaise
here English a called Mary Seacole
person is not total on America Lana Roni
Koval optimist now let's look at a few
sentences in writing but AHA no study it
aid the lioness Virata Rama to co-host
my suit and out to Turkey so what
language could it be
[Music]
the language is Estonian Estonian is the
official language of Estonia and is
spoken by around 1.1 million native
speakers mainly in Estonia but also by a
minority in Latvia it's a member of the
finnick branch of the Uralic language
family however around 30% of its
vocabulary is borrowed from other
language families like Germanic it's
closely related to finish and more
distantly related to Hungarian and like
both of them it's a largely
agglutinative language when looking at
the written samples a hint that this
might be Estonian is the vowel
diacritics these vowels with umlaut
diacritics also exist in Finnish but
this vowel and O with the tilt is not
used in Finnish another hint is that you
see lots of doubled vowel letters to
represent long vowels and on to the next
language please listen with rosa la da
gachi molybdenum trees or even a Paris
castor - a penniless American TV channel
Parc güell Acropolis perturbs this is -
aluminium ecology Sam Craig Nettles hell
mineral or tar weapon so that marry
Sayoko nation dinner and course quality
with radicals the algae at hidden column
are joinin appears a Casa de mis alpha
BC today now we'll look at a few
sentences in writing may mean - original
concert smelly man biblioteca Danzig
neat Hollow
mayor vive Schmidt umm Salama so what
language could this possibly be the
language is Georgian Georgian is the
official language of Georgia a country
in the Caucasus region of Western Asia
adjacent to Eastern Europe it's a member
of the cart valayan language family an
independent language family that is not
related to the indo-european family or
any other language family as far as we
know cart Valiant is also part of the
language group called the caucasian
languages because of its location in the
caucasus region but the caucasian
languages are not actually a language
family but a regional grouping georgian
is known for its rich phonology in
particular in its consonants one feature
is ejected consonants ejected consonants
are globalised meaning that they are
produced with
simultaneous injection of air from the
glottal area you do this by closing your
glottis which feels like you're holding
your breath for a second then you open
the glottis with a burst of air while
you produce the consonant listen to the
first consonant of this word unset
smelling and this one seeking another
feature is that it contains many
consonant clusters peevish m'p unset
smelly some of these can get quite long
but innately another language please
listen to me amiss it can but it should
be minibar Eden is Kim dr. Jinga dasa
someday I have my own soccer I cannot
build medium Rumble medium as shittin
blue media engineers most even vinegar I
know hon she hasn't been easy to learn
or ask on now here are the written
samples mean Kim satavahana caleda
o can cut a powder and chaos scheming so
what language do you think it might be
[Music]
the language is Kazakh Kazakh is a
member of the kipchak branch of the
Turkic language family it has around 15
million native speakers the majority of
them in Kazakhstan where it's the
official language one feature of Kazakh
which is a feature of Turkic languages
in general is vowel harmony vowel
harmony means that the presence of one
vowel can determine the vowels that
appear in subsequent syllables in Kazakh
if the last vowel in a word stem is a
back vowel the vowels and suffixes must
be back vowels as well this is the word
meaning writers with the plural suffix
at the end because the last vowel of the
stem is a back vowel the plural suffix
has a back vowel too if the first vowel
of a word stem is a front vowel then all
the vowels that follow both in the stem
and in suffixes must be front vowels and
this is the word meaning ships because
the first vowel of the word stem is a
front vowel the next vowel is a front
vowel and the plural suffix contains a
front vowel to recent loan words from
other languages like Russian are an
exception and don't necessarily
have vowel harmony okay let's check one
final language massacred on must be a
hairy magic holy to famous river ah hey
I got a vague hallelula hoop art oh let
me post aqua so today me sang get a veto
getting me Lito today me come Jake ahem
ETTs corto ik multiple angle heavy
colectomy bus the last Oh Jake I wrote
zakah master Dima Sega Colima Ducato and
now some written samples melaka hiccup
leg had say a hip DNA grant aliamanu
acoustic was not Hitler
Asura 3 media nahi so what language do
you think it is the language is Marathi
Marathi is a language spoken in India in
the state of Maharashtra and in parts of
neighboring states and union territories
in terms of the number of native
speakers it's the third most spoken
language with close to 90 million people
speaking it as a mother tongue that's
specifically within the borders of India
if we count indo-aryan languages in all
locations then Punjabi would be third
since many of its speakers are in
Pakistan Marathi is an indo-aryan
language however it's undergone
significant influence of Dravidian
languages which is understandable when
you see that it's spoken in areas
adjacent to areas where Dravidian
languages are spoken like all indo-aryan
languages a large amount of Marathi
vocabulary developed from Sanskrit but
with different word forms since it's had
many centuries to diverge but it also
contains a large amount of words which
were intentionally borrowed directly
from Sanskrit and closely resemble the
original Sanskrit words these words are
called tats Amma's and they are a
preferred source of vocabulary in
written marathi and are also used to
coin new technical words and the like
spoken marathi also contains many such
sanskrit borrowings
for example the word for after nun third
and the word for full or complete boom
these are everyday words and don't
necessarily belong to a formal register
like you would expect for sanskrit
loanwords
well that's the end
today's mystery languages video I hope
you had fun guessing and I hope that you
learned something new be sure to follow
Leng focus on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram and once again thank you to
all of my wonderful patreon supporters
especially these ones on the screen they
are my top tier patreon supporters so
many many thanks to them and to you
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
[Music]